all of show developer peter lenkov's
reboots of previous tv shows including
macgyver magnum pi and hawaii 5-0 share
the same fictional universe known as the
lenkav verse and have been substantial
hits for their parent network cbs
however the length of verse has seen a
great deal of controversy over the years
in 2017 regular hawaii five-o cast
members daniel day kim and grace park
left the series over a salary dispute
given how they were reportedly paid 10
to 15 percent less than series leads
alex o'laughlin and scott khan then in
2020 lenkov was fired from the three
shows by cbs after multiple claims that
he'd fostered a toxic work environment
as well as allegations that he was
abusive and manipulative on sets
nevertheless hawaii 5.0 did wrap up a
successful 240 episode run while
macgyver concluded in 2021 after five
seasons and magnum is still on the air
as of 2022 much of this of course is
behind the scenes stuff and even really
tense sets have been known to produce
entertaining works on the whole hawaii
five-o is precisely the kind of
action-packed police procedural drama
that's an easy fit for a multiple season
run however that doesn't mean the show
is entirely devoid of problematic
moments in front of the camera in fact
all those off-screen problems might have
meant that nobody noticed how bleak and
off-putting a particular season 10
plotters let's take a look at the hawaii
5.0 scene that the fans think went too
far in episode 14 of season 10 dany
meets an attractive woman at a bar and
they hit it off however as they head
home together the pair end up in a crash
after dany is forced to swerve to avoid
an oncoming car the woman is badly
injured and they're in a remote area
without cell reception dramatic and sad
scenes ensue and in the end she passes
away before help arrives without ever
telling the devastated dany her name
oh it's so crazy so funny i could i got
the luck like you said i meet the girl
in my dreams i get in a car accident
the plot is definitely sad but it
arguably feels off in a number of ways
chief among them is the fact that the
entire thing seems to run against dany's
characterization which is saying
something considering that the show's
had time to explore the character for
years and years at this point while dany
is incredibly faithful to his friends
he's also a rather melancholic and
reserved figure who's incredibly
unlikely to open the creaky armor of his
sarcastic exterior for a new
acquaintance as such it seems out of
character for dany to bond with someone
so quickly and unfair to have the
character go through another loss after
the murder of his partner and a messy
divorce this may be one of the reasons
why some fans feel the story is
contrived one hawaii 5-0 subreddit user
pointed out dany's out of character
behavior and felt that the storyline
only happened as quote another go for
peter lenkov to punish the character
as a whole the episode is clearly not a
fan favorite episode in fact with this
comparatively mega 6.8 imdb user rating
it's far and away the lowest rated
episode in the entire hawaii 5-0 season
10. apart from the way the episode both
portrays dany in a strange way and puts
him through the emotional ringer by
introducing a potential love interest
and taking her away within the span of a
single episode's run time viewers have
pointed out other issues in the episode
as well
multiple imdb user reviews concurred
that dany's behavior is off here and not
only in the dramatic death scene one
user pointed out that his first aid
skills are completely wrong and even
said that he directly contributes to the
woman's fate with his clumsy attempts to
save her what's more another user noted
that the terrifying incident is more or
less forgotten after the episode is over
since quote the police did not
investigate or judge the driver and they
never mention it again
come on come on come on come on
come on
come on
somebody
while scott khan gets a chance to flex
his dramatic muscles here his
character's big scene in this episode
has clearly bothered many people as has
a whole bunch of other stuff surrounding
it all in all definitely not the finest
hour of hawaii 5-0
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite awkward television moments
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]